. It's great to have back on the program after
I don't know how many years really, it feels
like a long time ago.
Holyoke, Massachusetts Mayor Alex Morse, who
now also is candidate for Congress in Massachusetts,
1st Congressional District, my old district.
I don't live there anymore.
But it was it was my district for a while.
Alex, it's great to have you on.
Yeah.
Thanks so much for having me back, David.
I think it's been about nine years.
I think it has been that long.
Yeah.
At the time, we were both much younger last
time.
Yeah.
Never be the same.
We look exactly the same.
That's the good news.
Yeah.
At least for now, five more years will be
a little different.
Anyway, if Trump wins for sure.
OK, so you're mayor of Holyoke and you're
running this Democratic primary campaign.
The primary is on September 1st.
People should already have requested and hopefully
have in hand ballots if they're voting absentee.
I know people that have already sent them
back in.
So this this is all sort of happening right
now.
Talk a little bit about your approach here.
As someone who is up against the longtime
incumbent in Richard Neal, someone that is
seen by some as part of the establishment,
someone that is seen by others as someone
who maybe is doing a good enough job, aware
where they would not want to see him replaced.
What's your approach here?
Yeah.
So we launched this campaign about 13 months
ago.
We knew it would take a great deal of work
to build the kind of movement across Western
Mass.
This is a district of eighty seven cities
and towns from the hill towns to the Berkshires,
rural parts of this district, down to urban
communities like Springfield and Holyoke.
And so, you know, we have a member of Congress
now that just is unable to grasp the urgency
of the moment on every issue.
He's absent.
He's unaccountable.
And he's been there for over 30 years.
And it's a different time than it was in the
late 1980s.
And it requires a different a different sort
of lens of which we view policy and just different
solutions to the challenges that we now have.
And so our goal has always been to build a
grassroots campaign.
We always knew we would get outspent and outraised.
And our goal was to make sure that we have
the people power, the grassroots campaign
and the resources that we need to defeat this
congressman.
On September 1st and you know, twelve months
later and 13 days out from the election, we
are well on our way to doing that.
And it's a testament to the people that have
just felt forgotten about and left behind
by the federal government in recent years.
So we'll talk.
You've had some big boosts in fundraising
over the last seven days, and we'll talk about
the genesis of all of that in a bit.
But as you point out, this is a district that
includes Springfield, Massachusetts, a city
that has a very, very different circumstances
and problems than places like I think Huntington
is also part of the district or, you know,
another very rural small town with one stoplight,
if anything.
So, I mean, what what Huntington needs and
what Springfield needs are two very, very
different things.
How do you assess working on both?
Yeah.
And so just yesterday we announced the support
of over 30 rural elected officials and community
leaders who feel very much forgotten about
and left behind that the perception now is
not only do we have a member of Congress that
hasn't had a town hall in the district in
over three years, but people want a member
of Congress that shows up, in particular in
the Hill towns and in the rural parts of the
district.
And whether you live in Holyoke or Springfield
or Huntington or Chester or North Adams, people
are feeling, again, not represented by this
current occupant of this seat.
And you would never know.
We have one of the most powerful members of
Congress representing us.
When you look at outcomes, the fact that dozens
of cities and towns still are without basic
access to broadband Internet, that we have
public schools closing in the hill, towns
that can't afford the costs of municipal health
insurance.
We have hospitals closing one in North Adams.
Hundreds have been patient psychiatric beds
closing here and Holyoke and in Camden County
and Springfield, still the asthma capital
of our entire country.
And I've made a commitment to having a rural
desk, making sure that we have a staff and
a presence in the hill towns and in the rural
parts of this district to make sure that everybody
that lives here in western and central mass
knows that they have an ally in Washington.
So most of my audience obviously doesn't live
in the Massachusetts 1st Congressional District,
but they live in the United States.
And so if you were to become a member of Congress,
you would be one of 435 votes on a whole bunch
of things that would affect people who are
in Florida or Los Angeles or wherever.
So I'd like to talk a little bit about your
approach to some of the big issues right now
that can sometimes be dividing lines when
we think about who should be representing
us.
So, like, for example, big picture on taxation.
We had a tax reform bill in 2017 from the
current administration and Republicans.
There's a view that taxes should be much.
Higher on some people or lower on others or
whatever the case may be to pick an issue
that is relatable to everybody.
What's your perspective on what Congress should
be doing on taxes?
Yeah, and I would.
I'll get to taxes in a moment.
But this is a race, and I want listeners to
know that has national implications because
I'm challenging the chairman of the House
Ways and Means Committee.
And I'm not contesting the fact that Congressman
Neal has power.
He has power as the chair of the Ways and
Means Committee.
But he's not using his power.
No.
One to hold this president accountable.
He dragged its feet for months to even request
the president's tax returns, refused to seize
the New York state returns that lawmakers
there worked for years to make available.
He was one of the last congressional Democrats
to embrace and support an impeachment agree
into this president.
And along with Elliot Engle is the only other
Democratic chair and leadership that hasn't
had a single oversight hearing on any component
of the Trump administration since the Democrats
took back the House.
And so instead of using his power for oversight,
he's using his power to again be complicit.
And many of the priorities of the Trump administration
is an ardent opponent of Medicare for all.
Even as millions of Americans are losing their
job and their employer based health insurance
is the only member of Congress here in Massachusetts
that refuses to sign on to the Green New Deal.
He, even in the middle of this pandemic, has
come out against a monthly recurring payment
of two thousand dollars to the most vulnerable
Americans that are being left behind.
He has opposed Pramila Jiah Paul's Paycheck
Guarantee Act, and right now he is literally
the number one recipient of corporate money
in the entire House of Representatives, more
than any Democrat.
And even more than every Republican.
And in regards to taxation in particular,
yes, this is a Congress, a Democrat that is
openly opposed to a wealth tax.
He has supported the carried interest loophole.
I mean, the Ways and Means Committee in particular
is the committee that should be doing oversight
hearings on the 2017 tax package.
He has done nothing to address it.
He has done nothing to raise the corporate
tax rate.
Instead, he is using his power to mitigate
the possibility politically of achieving a
wealth tax.
And if we defeat Congressman Neal on September
1st, it's all but assured that there will
be a member of the Progressive Caucus that
becomes chair of the Ways and Means Committee
that supports Medicare for all that supports
the Green New Deal, that supports a wealth
tax and a higher corporate tax rate that we
can actually invest in domestic priorities.
That would make a difference in people's lives
here in western Mass.
OK.
But to get back to my question a little bit
on, let's go.
Even more detailed then.
So you mentioned a wealth tax.
You mentioned a recurring payment during during
the pandemic.
Our current top marginal tax rate right now
is in the mid 30s.
Where do you think the top marginal tax rate
should be?
Do you want to see a higher bracket at 45,
50, 70 percent as some other potential future
colleagues of yours have suggested?
Where would you put that?
Yeah, I'm much more in line with Elizabeth
Warren's concept of a wealth tax that the
wealthiest one percent.
Be it a penny or two on every dollar over
a certain amount of money.
And it is criminal in this country that working
families and middle class families are paying
essentially more in taxes to the federal government
than, you know, folks at Facebook and Google
and Amazon.
I mean, as a percentage of income, you mean
as a percentage of income?
Absolutely.
And I think we also need to take a closer
look at modern monetary theory.
Made these archaic views of the deficit and
government spending.
I mean, we have the resources we need to fight
climate change to provide health care as a
fundamental human right to provide free public
college.
But when you have Democrats like Congressman
Neal pedaling right wing talking points about
the deficit and our inability to make these
investments at the very time 60 percent of
our federal budget goes to the Pentagon, I
mean, we need members of Congress, not just
not just any Democrat, but Democrats that
actually understand this to go to Washington
and just change the conversation in regard
to these issues on Pentagon funding.
How specifically would you propose reducing
it?
I mean, would you close bases in places like
Germany, for example?
Yeah, I think I think first and foremost,
we need to evaluate the necessity of having
dozens of military bases around the world.
And I think we need to have a foreign policy
that isn't.
Isn't eager to sort of get itself involved
in unnecessary coups if democratically elected
leaders around the world.
And let me think again.
60 percent of our federal budget goes to war
in defense.
I think it's completely unacceptable.
And I think there was some good effort among
the Democrats to reduce it by 10 percent.
But I think I mean, that's the flaw.
And I think we need to continue going further
than that.
So this race, the Massachusetts 1st Congressional
District, has been not only does it have national
implications, as you point out, but it's also
become very interesting to all sorts of different
folks around the country over the last 10
days because of a controversy that started
when the Massachusetts College Democrats put
out a letter sort of generally alleging, but
without naming any individuals or putting
names to it, alleged inappropriate actions
by you when it comes to personal relationships,
when you were teaching a course at the University
of Massachusetts and in your role there working
with with college Democrats at UMass.
And this has exploded to the point where,
you know, Glenn Greenwald has been tweeting
about it.
Ryan Green, all sorts of people I follow on
fit.
You know, I've known you for a decade and
people that had I had never mentioned you
before or tweeting about it, this has exploded.
Now, you've been able to raise a lot of money
as a result.
And I want to talk about whether you think
maybe it has backfired to some degree.
But first of all, the sort of core of it is,
do you accept that you have acted inappropriately
at any point in any way, or do you reject
the allegations on principle?
I reject the allegations on principle.
I mean, evidence has now come to light that
essentially proves that this was a coordinated
political attack.
On behalf of supporters of the congressmen
that were, in fact trying to curry favor with
one of the most powerful incumbents in Washington,
I mean, this was a story that was shopped
around to mainstream media for months.
And every journalist rejected it because it
was vague.
It was nonspecific.
No one would go on record.
I mean, this was essentially a blog post that
was printed in a student newspaper that was
unamplified to the local media buys by media
here across Massachusetts and by national
media outlets.
And now, thanks to the investigative reporting
of The Intercept and the journalist there,
we have now I mean, pretty much by the day.
I've learned more and more behind the political
motivations of this that goes to the height
of the Massachusetts Democratic Party itself.
And I have been very clear and unapologetic
about my identity as a young, single gay person
and not having to apologize for having relationships,
consensual relationships with other adult
men in my life.
And do you say that there are individuals
associated with and looking to curry favor
with your opponent?
But at this point, do you allege that your
opponent either knew that this was being done
or was involved in any way?
I mean, I think it is certainly suspicious
and I will let the people of the district
come to their own conclusions, but I think
people are certainly seeing this for what
it is that three weeks before the most competitive
election that this member of Congress has
ever seen, this suddenly happens.
I mean, it is no accident.
It is no coincidence.
And so people are seeing through it.
And then the language that has been used in
response, I mean, age-Old, homophobic tropes.
Yes, there have been youth, right.
Gay men who are all too familiar with the
overpolicing of our personal lives and our
sex lives.
I mean, this the response to this hasn't just
been an attack on me as a candidate and as
a person.
And it has had a great impact.
But it's been an attack on all of us and our
entire community and certainly invigorated
our supporters, invigorated the people here
in the district, and has invigorated and inspired
people to get off the sidelines into this
race that
that we're
in involved before.
Let's pause our conversation there with Holyoke,
Massachusetts, Mayor Alex Morse, who is, of
course, a candidate
for Congress
in the Massachusetts 1st Congressional District
Democratic primary.
The full conversation with him will be up
on
our YouTube channel, YouTube dot com slash